TAMPA BAY IN THE FIVE GAMES AT
THIS Y Y ON DRY
1500 NHL GA AND
JAKE ALLEN TURNED OVER BEHIND
HIS NET BUT  VERY
FLORID MIND GOOD PASSING ALL RH
GOOD HOCKEY SETS. THE BLUES
UNIFORMS IT'S GET BELLA BACK AN
AND IT PASSED NOW BY KROGHSLOT
TEAM A GREAT PARTNER. KROGH
>> ABOUT
AND NOW DAVID SAVARD BACK UP IS
ON GOAL THIS ISNOW I PASS BY WH
TSUZUKI BUDDY WAS ON HIS OWN
SIDE OF CENTER IC
>> LET'S FACE IT IT'S A SHELL O
ON GOAL SAVED BY ALLEN AND NOW
KYRA BACK HE OUT AND
HELD ON THERE'S NO WAY TO GET
THE P P
LOOK REALLY REALLY EASY THAT  H
OUT HIGH THE PASS ALLEN
MADE A GOOD SAVE NO CHANCE FOR
OF DAVIS SOUGHTHT
JUST A TERRIFIC SET UP AT ALALG
VACCO MEANS THAT GATEWAY HONDA
DEALERS WE GET $500 TO GRAB THE
WISH OF A CRITICALLY. AND
WE GET A WHISTLE. TERRACING BRO
HAS WIDENED THEM PITCHING AND I
THE ST. LOUIS GETS IT BACK ON
THE GOALACKHAND ANY
KIND OF BEGAN HAND ON IT WHICH
LIKE THAT YOU KNOW THE GUYS ON
THE EYES OF THEIR TEAM THAT'S
DEFENDING YOU SEE ON THE LEFT
FIC PLAY
BY SWARMING THE PRODUCT LOOKS.
THAT WAS STOPPED.
>> OPT THE FACE-OFF USE LOGAN
BROWN
FACE-OFF IT WHEN NAGGING INJURY
AND THAT FOR JAKE.
HE HAD A BOWL AS IN